So the bigger the vision you have, the more
important it is for you on what type of a
team you're going to put around you.
Simple as that.
And I think one of the challenges with people
when it's about putting a team around them,
they want to be something they're not.
So it's everybody wants to be the Shaq or
the LeBron or the Kobe instead of realizing
what your strength is.
I'm going to talk about that a little bit
today.
I'm going to talk about 10 different roles,
strengths and departments within a company.
So as you're looking at this, everybody that's
looking at this, you may be at a different
position in your life.
You may be a salesperson, you may be an entrepreneur
that's just getting started, maybe a mid-size
business, that you may look at this and say
that this is where we lack or maybe somebody
that's an executive and an owner part of a
company that's saying this is what area I
am very good at and I need to reposition myself
here.
Regardless of where you're at, this is how
I want you to look at this here.
This video is for you.
No one else.
I want you to look at this video as you.
And as I go through this, I need you to ask
yourself, which one is me.
Give me your one, two, three, yourself.
I'm one this, two this, three this.
And, if you think that's you, verify it with
somebody who knows you very well for them
to say I really think you're more this, this,
this - if you're willing to get some honest
feedback from somebody.
So let's get right into it.
Look, 10 different roles within a company.
First, we have the biz dev.
And nothing is any specific order, I'm just
telling you what's what.
First you have the biz dev, someone who's
doing business development for the company.
What is biz dev?
Here's what biz dev is.
In the world of politics, if you're running
a country, an ambassador that is a U.S. ambassador
that deals with relations in the Middle East
-- hypothetically.
The biz dev person is doing the dirty work.
Very, very important role.
But they do the dirty work.
So you need to go out there and sit and talk
to the political powers, the senators, the
congressmen, the president of a country in
the Middle East - Iran, Kuwait, whatever it
is, and ask them.
They're going to say, "we really don't like
your president, that he announced this, this,
this," or "We really don't like how this partnership
or relationship's going.
We don't like how you're doing this."
That's biz dev.
And the ambassador is supposed to create a
synergy of them still wanting to do business
together.
And bringing the relationship that possibly
was sour, rekindle, this is strengthen, this
is rebuild, this is a lot of re, re, re -- that's
biz dev, okay?
Next, we can go into the visionary.
The visionary is what a lot of people want
to become visionaries but not everybody is
a visionary.
Let me explain to you what I mean by not everybody
is a visionary.
If you ask in basketball, everybody wants
to be like Mike.
Modern day.
Everybody wanted to be a Kobe.
Or everybody wants to be a LeBron James.
But maybe you're a Steve Kerr, you know?
Maybe you're somebody that's a, you know,
Steph Curry.
Maybe you're somebody that's just a role player.
Maybe you're a sixth man.
Maybe you're a big guy that you don't have
good footwork, but you're somebody that the
other centers get good on working with you
because you're stronger, you're pushing them
and bullying them, you're strengthening them.
Maybe you're somebody that's good at playing
with the guys and doing their legs and taping
and all this other stuff.
So what is the role you're playing?
A visionary would generally be called the
CEO.
Now sometimes, some companies make the mistake
of just because somebody's title is CEO, it
doesn't mean they're a visionary.
Sometimes companies make a mistake and they
hire a operations person who becomes a CEO
and what this guy who's an operations internally
but is the CEO, all he's trying to do is make
all the systems perfect.
And they're wondering how come the company's
not exploding, because you're not a CEO.
You're operations.
You're a COO., not a CEO.
You're not a face.
You're not someone that's going to say, "We're
going to go and take over this market."
Let me give you a good example of a CEO.
I'm going to butcher his name.
Roberto Goizueta - This guy is a fascinating
guy to study.
He's a Cuban immigrant, went to Yale, just
so you know this, he used to make $500 a month
as a chemical engineer, then he comes to America
and somehow, some way, after being an immigrant
from Cuba, he becomes the CEO of Coca Cola
and he goes from making $500 a month to getting
an $83 million bonus check when he worked
at Coca Cola.
So why is this?
Why did this happen?
Well, for the longest time, for the longest
time, Coca Cola dominated the marketplace.
For the longest time.
Now, in the early 80s, Pepsi started coming
close to the point where Pepsi got 23% of
the market share and Coca Cola only had 22%.
Now, Roberto gets hired in 1981 I believe.
And his number I just gave you, 23% to 22%,
Pepsi over Coke, Pepsi moved past Coke, first
time ever.
First time ever.
They passed Coke, Roberto comes in.
And here's what he asked.
Look at the way he thinks.
He says, Well, I want to know this.
The average human being, how much do they
drink a day?
And they said, Roberto, this is how much we're
selling right now, bottles of Coke.
He said, no, no.
I'm asking you how much do they consume of
drinks per day.
What are you talking about?
Listen, how much does a person drink - water,
milk, tea, juice, ice-tea, Coke -- I want
to know everything.
How much does a person drink?
They're like, Oh my God, where is this guy
going with this thing here?
Here's how they drink.
Then he said, that's exactly what we need
to do.
I want a bigger market share of how much somebody
consumes of drinks.
Fascinating.
Look what happens then.
So what does he come out with?
Here's what he comes out with.
Most of us only know about Coca Cola, Diet
Coke, Coke Zero, etc.
Ready?
Minute Maid is a Coke product, Fanta is a
Coke product, Dasani water is a Coke product,
Nestea is a Coke product, Bicardi Mixers is
a Coke product.
Okay?
Flavored milks, root beer, bottled juices,
Zico coconut water -- you know how many people
like to drink coconut water - Powerade, his,
Simply Orange his, Hi-C, his.
You know what ends up happening with Coca
Cola?
Coca Cola goes from the top of numbers that
we're putting up which in 1981 was 4.3 billion
dollars per year to 152 billion dollars per
year.
They're today selling two billion Coca Cola
bottles per day, two billion is what they
sell per day.
Now, why did that happen?
It happened because Coca Cola went and hired
a visionary.
Not because they got an operations guy - they
hired a visionary.
And the visionary said, we need to get more
of this.
So are you a CEO type yourself?
That could motivate you, but maybe you're
not the visionary type, and that's fine.
Operations, what's operations?
Systems, CRM, flow, how long does it take
from the person that looks at your website
to buying the product to converting to being
a be back customer, what can we make to get
these customers that we have.
We have 60,000 customers here, what can we
do to get the 60,000 customers to help us
get to their 60,000 customers because we're
so good on the front end, we're not doing
good on this side here.
What CRM do we need?
How can we get the calendars to be better,
hiring new people, we need more staff here,
we need a person here, we need to fire this
person, we need to renegotiate this here,
this thing's not working out, this vendor.
. . that's operations.
Operations are thinking like that.
Operations will come in and say, I can make
the operations of this better.
So critical.
Maybe boring to some, it's so critical for
the company.
So that would be a COO.
Then we have finance.
Finance is QuickBooks, payroll, commissions,
vendor checks, attorneys, making sure attorneys,
you're negotiating the contracts with the
attorneys the right way.
CPA, accounting, the team, assistant analyst,
all these things that you're going to have
to do when you're running finance.
By the way, when you're a rookie entrepreneur,
guess what you are?
Every one of them is what you are, okay?
So then you have the CFO on the finance side.
Then you have expansion.
Who's expansion?
Somebody that says, you know, we need to go
to a brand new marketplace.
So expansion thinks about building a team
together, for us to go to a new market.
This could be a Chief Expansion Officer -- there's
actually a Chief Expansion Officer -- it sounds
like a CEO but it's a Chief Expansion Officer.
And they're job is simply, hey, we're not
on the East Coast, we want to go into the
East Coast, what do we need to do?
Bop, bop, bop, bop, bop.
Great.
Hey, we're not in South America, what do we
need to do?
. . . . . For you, it may be local.
Like somebody came and visited me when I was
in Palm Springs.
He drove all the way down to come and visit
me and he runs a mobile detailing company.
Which I'm very familiar with the mobile detailing
company, and nowadays it's getting to the
app side, there's a lot of opportunity to
that as well, similar to Uber that you just
order something and somebody comes and services
your car, right?
And there's high end, $100, like right now,
literally three minutes before I did the video,
my BMW i8, just got serviced.
Somebody comes, does it, you don't even see
it, it gets done, they pick it up, they clean
it, right?
Okay.
So he came to me and he said, what do I do?
So he's in San Diego, and how does he get
into maybe a Temecula market?
How does he get into Riverside?
How does he get into L.A.?
The expansion for that person may be within
that area.
Somebody can put a strategy in how to do that.
Marketing.
Marketing is just very, very critical.
This could be a CMO.
Marketing could be when a customer thinks
about our company, what's the first word that
comes to mind?
What do our employees think about our company?
What do our customers, what does the market,
what does our competitors, what does our enemy
think about us?
How do we want to market our product?
Which funnels are we using?
Is it more about social media?
Is it more about Internet?
Should we go on T.V.?
What is our ROI on T.V.?
Are we really doing this because we want people
to look at our commercial and come and buy?
They don't really do it for that, but maybe
it's effective if we spend this 3.5 million
dollars to put a commercial on Super Bowl
because our competitors are going to see that
we're doing better or, you know, maybe our
existing customers are going to say, "Wow,
I'm so glad that's my guy, that's my guy,"
so it keeps our clients with us and keeps
them proud.
Or no, we don't need to do Super Bowl.
It's not our market.
Our market watches this or, you know, our
demographic is people that are between 25
- 35 years old, our guys watch T.V.
Our guys don't watch soap operas.
Why are we wasting our time doing.
. . so marketing thinks that way.
Okay?
Complete different way.
Marketing in a way also thinks about, a person
who's a marketer -- if you're a marketer,
you know how you think.
Marketer's think completely different.
They go into a restaurant and they literally
look at everything as a marketer.
It's a complete different eyeball that they
have.
Next is legal.
What's legal?
In every industry there's compliance.
There's laws, there's you know, making sure
you are compliant with the regulators or whatever
- with the financial industry it's FINRA,
it's SEC, you know, all these other things
that you're dealing with on that side.
And real estate it's going to be Department
of Real Estate, the department of insurance
-- it doesn't matter what's you're doing.
Technology is going to be a whole different
law -- anything, there is legal.
So you've got to make sure you have a strong
legal team.
Sometimes the A-type personality, don't like
to touch this because it's -- we don't need
any help with this.
Why would we worry about compliance?
C'mon, man.
No one cares about compliance.
Big mistake.
Because you need the contracting to be right.
. . I spend a lot of money in that area and
I have no problem with it because it's very,
very critical to stay compliant with your
business.
But you may be watching this and saying, that's
me.
I love those types of things.
Phenomenal.
It could be information.
What's information?
Someone that's very good at research, someone
that's very good at studying competition,
somebody that's very good at studying trends
and keeping track of updating and saying,
just so you know, today in the market . . . AIG
CEO was called out.
. . and this is what happened with him and
they said this, and did you hear about what
happened today in the Silicon Valley marketplace,
a new startup was raised 200 million dollars
on their round three and their going after
this and did you hear about the Fintech market,
whatever.
Information guys are going to give you what
is going on today.
And this is beneficial because this helps
the visionary know how to go to the next level,
this helps the marketer know what adjustments
to make, this helps the expansion person know
what marketplaces we need to go and expand
and what not to waste our money and resources
into.
This helps finance know how to adjust, hey,
this is what's going on over the next six
to 12 months, we should be experiencing this
or we should be experiencing that.
That's information, so CIO.
Then you have product development and product
development is what?
Product development is somebody that says,
I'm designing a product.
Typically, product development are wired in
a completely different way.
Completely different way.
They will take a look at this packaging and
they'll say, you know, I wonder why they put
these four things in the back?
I don't like it.
I think it makes it flimsy and I think the
packaging should be done a little bit different,
see how hard it is, this should be easier
because when you do it this way, sometimes
it's tougher, so it takes three seconds to
package this with the machine, and.
. . they just look at it different than you
and I do.
A product development person could say, we
need to come out with a mortgage product today
that is going to make the regulators happy
because the regulators are very concerned
about not having a neg am product that's a
payment or negative amortization, that's not
going to effect this, so to come out with
this, but to make the cost low, why don't
we get rid of this?
Great.
They work in a completely different way.
Very important for product development to
be in communication with the rest of the guys.
Regularly in the insurance agency I get calls
and I sit on several different boards, that
they'll call me and they'll say, "What do
you think the insurance, financial industry
needs to look at right now, next as a product?
And we'll have a long conversation about areas
that I believe they need to completely change
and revolutionize because the insurance industry
needs a lot of disruption right now.
Then you have sales.
By the way, nothing happens without sales.
Just so you know this.
So a lot of times, we put so much attention
into everything else, so much attention, every
position is very important.
Every position is very important.
That you forget to put constant emphasis here
[sales].
If you look at companies that go through this
-- they start going through a downfall, you
will see, almost every single time, if it
goes through this, 80% of the time, you can
go and point it to sales.
Why?
A great sales manager is no longer there.
A chairman of agency who was running the entire
sales department has gotten too casual because
his bonuses are so easy now that he knows
he's going to hit the bonus within four months,
and he's golfing four months out of the year.
You've got to make some changes to the bonus
structure, right?
So you have a person that is barely working
and you know nothing about it because everything
is based on no schedule, so you think he's
working, but he's not and you need to make
an adjustment and go and partner with Salesforce.com
because you need to make sure that the guys
are logging in every single day, what appointment
they ran, and who was the person with and
put a number there and you need to run a minimum
of this many appointments, you need to spend
this much money, you cannot spend more than
this at a bar and . . . to track that.
You can see this.
You may be somebody watching this and saying,
I'm a salesperson, I'm a great sales trainer,
I'm a great person that can build an army.
And here's the weird thing.
You want to know something?
They [sales] typically make more money than
every one of these guys.
Just so you know this.
These guys typically make the most money.
I know this sounds strange.
They definitely make more money than these
guys [finance through product development].
They make generally the most money, because
if these guys are not getting paid, what's
the motivation behind -- the company's done.
You think Coca Cola survives without their
guys that are going out there selling Coca
Cola to the local -- no, it's a done deal.
So sales is very, very critical.
You've got to look at this and you may say,
"Pat, you know what, I'm very good with people.
I can pretty much go in a room and strike
up a conversation with anybody and get information
and talk to people and they'll tell me anything
and I'm a chameleon, I can get along.
. . well, you may be a biz dev person.
Good for you.
I'm a very strong sales person.
I can sell.
I'm good with sales.
I know how to ask the right questions.
I know that sales flow.
I'm good at teaching this.
Excellent.
I'm a visionary.
I'm this.
I'm that.
Regardless of what you are, you've got to
really take an assessment of yourself and
ask, what is my strength, top three, what
is my dominate one that I am?
For yourself.
And what can I do to become better at that
by studying others who have done those areas.
Now the complete opposite side, if you're
running a company, you've got to ask, who
is who?
What am Iacking?
Generally as a startup, you're going to wear
seven different hats.
When you get started, you may be the visionary,
the biz dev, the sales, the operations, the
finance, the expansion, all of these.
And you may have an attorney that you put
on retainer that you have hired, but they're
helping you and you give them $10,000 as a
retainer and everything else for you.
You're Chief Information Officer is a guy
named Google.
You know, that's what you do.
You're Googling everything to find out what
it is, right?
So it doesn't matter what it is.
Eventually if you want to compete at the higher
market and if you want to get the bigger share
of whatever industry you're part of, you need
all of these 10 different guys on your team
and you need to know which role you play the
best and become the best you can within that
area, while knowing how all the other people
are wired as well.
So hopefully today you may say, "Pat, so what
was really the outcome of this video?"
To kind of know what each person does and
to kind of know what's needed to build a strong
team, strong foundation, again, this is another
one of those episodes that I can go three
more hours with you and just go dive extremely
deep into this and break everything down and
address questions, but this is a simple video
we're doing on the YouTube channel.
Maybe in another setting we'll have an opportunity
to dive a little deeper into this subject.
So by the way, for those of you guys that
are looking at these shirts, we've sold hundreds
of these around the world already.
If you haven't purchased one, this is the
entrepreneur's uniform.
Everybody, if you consider yourself an entrepreneur,
everybody ought to have this shirt.
I'm pretty much wearing this thing every single
day.
If I'm at the airport, if I'm walking around
anywhere, if I could wear this every day,
I have every single color that we have, I
think I've got a red one, I've got a blue
one, I've got a green one, I've got a black
one, and I think I've got all the colors,
so if you want to get one of these shirts,
I'm an Entrepreneur, go to ValuetainmentStore.com.
If you go to ValuetainmentStore.com you can
order your shirt there and put it on, and
when you do get it, take a picture and tag
us, whether it's on Instagram, you can take
me on Instagram or take a picture on Snapchat
and send it to me, BetDavid19, you can follow
it, then if you haven't subscribed to the
channel, please do so.
If you've got any questions about this, post
your questions and comments on the bottom.
Take care everybody.
Bye bye.